Western globalist elites will continue to
assert their exclusivity
pit people and split society
provoke bloody conflicts and
coups sow hatred Russophobia
aggressive nationalism
and destroy family traditional
values ​​that make a person a
man of the height of their military labor and
moral achievements
we are proud of the participants of a special
military operation of all who fight  to the
front line Who, under fire, provides the
front rescues the wounded No now it is more important
than your Combat work
on you today the security of the
country rests on you the future of our
statehood and our people depends